good evening members of the council
ladies and gentlemen welcome to this
evening's meeting of the southeastern
area planning committee
held in the council chamber morgan
district council offices
agenda item one
over chairman's notices
uh recording of the meeting please note
that the council will be recording and
publishing on the council's website any
part of this meeting held in open
session
fire in the event of a fire a siren will
sound please use the fire exits marked
with the green running man
the fire assembly point is outside the
main entrance to the council offices
please
gather there and await further
instruction
health and safety please be advised of
the different levels of flooring within
the council chamber
there are steps behind the main
horseshoe as well as to the side of the
room closed circuit television meetings
held in the council chamber are being
monitored and recorded by cctv
and lift the lift is currently out of
order so please contact
vicki clark sounds a bit late for that
for any queries
uh
agenda item two apologies for absence
um
tara please
thank you very much
agenda item 3 minutes of the last
meeting found on pages 7-16
to confirm the minutes of the meeting of
the committee held on the 19th of may
anybody got any questions
no agreed
all right thank you very much
the gender item for disclosure of
interest said it slightly changed is to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
registrable interests and
non-registerable interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph nine
and appendix b of the code of conduct
for members
and members are reminded that they also
require to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
any members cancer misses sorry brain's
gone
wendy
i'm offended yes wendy it's all right
any teasing um just that i'm a member of
essex county council i'm declaring a
non-procurement interest because they're
a statutory council team i've looked at
today and i don't think there's a
problem chairman thank you
signing off
any other members
in that case we move on
to agenda item 5 the millefields caravan
park
to consider the report of director of
service delivery
thank you chairman
so
yes that's good so the application site
is approximately two hectares in size
has a lawfully used as a carbon site
and it is located to
the
um
west of station road and the 200 sports
center
uh north of the river crowd which is
down here and outside the settlement
boundary
planning permission for the erection of
a single story multi-purpose building
that one here formation of heart
stunting to be used as an access road
and
provide off-street parking and the
stationing of a total of 52 caravans was
approved on the 13th of september 2019
under the terms of application 18
00381 slash ful
the current proposal which is on the
right hand side here
six permission to vary conditions two
and three in relation to the previously
approved plans
uh to intensify the existing use of the
site increasing the number of caravans
on sites from 52 to 55
with their associated car parking spaces
the three additional caravans are
proposed
here in this area in the southern part
of the
application site
uh no other changes are proposed in
relation to the approved layout or or
the multi-purpose um building or hard
standing or landscaping apart from what
already been said
so this is slightly closer view of the
revised
layout plan
these are the proposed floor plans and
elevations of the previously approved
multi-purpose units you need no no
changes to that i just included it for
um clarity
um
and these are some photographs of the
site
this is the access uh vehicular access
to the site um the southern part of the
site and the northern part of the site
um this is
from station road looking to the south
and looking to the east along station
road
and these are views from river crowds
for to the south
uh having taken all material planning
considerations into account it is
considered that the amended proposal
would be acceptable in planning terms
and in principle and it will accord with
policies s8 and e5 of the ldp
the impact of the development of the
character of the area and the amenities
of the nearby
neighboring properties has been assessed
and found to be acceptable
the amended proposal would not result in
an unacceptable impact on highway safety
or the free flow of traffic and it would
provide sufficient off-street parking to
meet the needs of the amended
development
the scheme
would not result in a material increase
in flood risk on-site or elsewhere and
surface water will be managed by
condition
the amended development by reason of its
scale nature would not pose any
additional threat to the nature
conservation sites to the south or
protected species
from that already
assessed and found acceptable under the
terms of the previously approved
application for these reasons the
development is considered acceptable
and in accordance with the aims of the
development plan and is recommended for
for approval subject to conditions on
pages 26 to 28 of the agenda
thank you thank you
any members have a viewpoint
hang on just one moment you have two
minutes when it's all ready
excellent thank you okay when you're
ready thank you very much
a little bit of the site context
and that really just begins for about
eight or nine years ago when the
undercover's turning for the land with
the vision for the site and as we don't
know in the last sort of eight or nine
years the driving forces for the economy
have hugely shifted over that pretty
long period of time
and because of that there's made so many
waves of changes to the way that holiday
can probably should occur in the uk and
the
the holiday park operators and in the
teams that offer other parks just to
respond to these driving forces so the
revised player of this proposal reflects
that change to capture these changes and
they kind of climbing and the increasing
rise and all the members are choosing to
or or
in some cases needing to stay in the uk
for their holidays rather than go abroad
so what's being proposed is simply a
layout that takes the most advantage of
site and its assets and its potential
for deliveries as a holiday park um
within your district and so in closing
i'd just like to thank you for this
opportunity to speak thanks thanks
thank you very much
all right members counsel mrs stamp you
wanted to speak good chairman thank you
very much i'm afraid i actually don't
agree with the speaker
and the officers
um i've read it in quite a lot of detail
and i've put squished these are my words
anyway squished because you do forgive
me
um it breaches um the application site
is outside the divine settlement
boundary which we all know that
sometimes this council seems to do it
does identify i i tend to intensify
intensifies chairman at the the site
three caravan sounds minimal but if you
actually look at the way it's actually
been positioned on there
50 is it 53 and we're going up to 55 or
52 going up to 55 chairman
um i think it does make a substantial
difference
um
i don't like the way it's crammed in the
idea was this was supposed to be a a
really nice
well-laid out
caravan
site yes there has been one there since
it says here 2006 i think it was there
before then but i won't split hairs
um i think
um you've got three hard standings for
um car parking spaces that's another
three bits of concrete
um i can't see that there's any more
cycle
bay's been made i think it's one to four
is it on the report wonderful
even with the increase of three more
caravans we're not actually going to
green we're not going to look at
reducing the car journeys we all know
how difficult it is going to be to go
down station road mill fields to get to
that site so to me three cut three vans
maybe seem minor but every time we're
getting a planning application in
burnham on crotch everybody's coming
back and saying can i have three more
five more ten more or twenty five more
well you only have to keep adding that
up mr chairman and it actually equates
to quite a substantial more houses or
caravans that we're getting so i
actually don't support that at the
moment so if you just bear with me
um
got a couple more things if i can find
them
um i don't agree it's not going to
impact on the ecology i think it will
because more people equates to more um
more usage more i don't know carbon
dioxide coming out monoxide coming into
the air
i like the way the um developer or the
agent turned down and said they were
driving forces of the economy and it
makes it sound as though we're doing a
fa they're doing us a favor by putting
more caravans on that site i don't think
they're doing a favor to anybody but
themselves on their own bottom line i
think this council has been
very very accommodating throughout the
whole of this length period and i think
molden at malden burnham residents have
had quite a raw deal on this um i won't
be supporting it i'm sure it'll go
through but i won't support it because i
do agree it changes and squidging in
extra caravans in a month's time we're
going to switch all them up to get a
little bit more space and i think it
changes the layout and i think it does
intensify the site chairman thank you
thank you
mrs hole
thank you
um also it just i'm talking on 5.4.1
um it's got horse riding routes i just
wondered where the horse riding roots
plan to be
three determine um this is this is from
policy d1 there aren't any horse riding
roads within the site
this is what what policy d16 to um
to include in terms of vehicle and
cycle access but that doesn't
necessarily mean that every single site
will have a horse riding groud that
traverses the site this one doesn't have
one at the moment
this is this is this is the policy this
is this is this comes from policy d1
it's not it it says that we will we will
make provision and we will protect them
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
every single site will have one
yes why hasn't it got one
never been applied for i suppose in the
original application
as far as i'm aware there isn't any
bridal way
coming through the site
i'm not aware of that
thank you chairman um just just to
remind members what this application is
about
um the application um seeks an
alteration
um to condition two amendment condition
to
to um
accommodate three additional caravans
that's all that's been applied for
the
principle of the development is as
largely the same layer except for the
three as approved that has been approved
it has permission
we can't
introduce additional
um
elements into it unless that's what was
applied for uh by the the applicant
that's not been applied for is just for
the three units so
it cannot be judged against any other
criteria apart from what's been applied
for as a change to the existing
permission thank you chairman
okay
i think
yeah it's unfortunate the wording of
area i
i understand why there's been some
confusion with it uh council mrs
chandler was next
thank you chairman actually i was going
to say
uh what the officer had said and i have
totally through the sentiments of
council hull because i know she's very
keen and makes the case every time with
applications and it was a pity that
actually by the time we considered the
initial application perhaps we didn't
then try and um
um see if the developer would
incorporate something then but we are
where we are and unfortunately this is
as the officer said
a variation of conditions to have the
extra three caravans so
i i think we lost out at that earlier
stage unfortunately
it is certainly something we seem to be
having happen on a regular basis because
nearly all these applications have come
forward somebody said well where's the
horse ropes and the montany council
passenger
thank you mr chairman um i would just
like to to
carry on with uh with the points that
council stamp was making and the word
squidged and the fact that
we we agree something and it comes
before we all agree it and then it comes
back and they want to put in another
three things but when you look at that
if you add another three it actually
affects everybody in that area because
if you squidge on another three then all
the rest have to sort of kind of like
squish up a little bit more and move
around because it isn't just putting
three on it would affect everybody who's
there but i just think it sets a
precedent that every time we approve a
planning application and there are
conditions it pops straight back and
somebody wants to either remove those
conditions or advance those in
conditions in some form
so i i won't be supporting it that is
the right of the applicant they can
always absolutely they can always change
any any application that they've
originally done it's uh
for us to decide whether or not we can
justify agreeing or refusing that and
and that i am aware of but i just it
just becomes the norm that we agree
something and then they
come back which is their prerogative i
do understand
that it's difficult sometimes cancer flu
thank you chairman um
yeah look you know i
i take on board what councillor stamp
says and and you know she's got
everybody to be concerned with with the
situation in burnham but i think
chairman it's you know
paragraph 7.1 the
the bernamon crouch town council are
actually silent on this
so uh at the end of the day chairman we
know that you know we've got uh
uh a town council in burnham and and
they've not even commented on this so i
think that needs to be given uh a
certain amount of weight
so um
it's you know members have spoken to the
effects of this but if you if you look
where one of the caravan goes um you've
got a block of four in the middle next
to the uh
leisure center
and one additional ones goes in there
well you wouldn't be able to see that
anyway from from the outside and the
other two are putting
around the edge at the bottom there and
and the interesting thing also is is
looking at that chairman is is that
the the caravans on on the the
previously approved actually appear to
be much larger than the proposed ones
now look you know amongst my great
wealth and knowledge chairman i don't
have an algorithm that shows you how
many people stay in the caravan but if
they become smaller one presumes they're
less so i would have thought having
another three does it make a huge effect
i personally don't think so um that's
the view that i share with the officers
chairman so i think
you know i think that uh the applicant
and i always find it amusing chairman
when a scotsman speaks to economics uh
but i suspect the economics of this is
as much to do with birch's making this
profitable
and and while i speak to that chairman i
really do think that we should have all
applied for a dispensation on this
because this is council property and we
should have a dispensation to vote on
this so chairman i think we should take
that on mass now as read because
otherwise we could
we couldn't
we couldn't make well we can't make a
decision in theory because it's our
property so um there should be a
dispensation there chairman and and all
of that said chairman you know i think
when you look at the effect of this the
offices are correct and i would
therefore propose german that we agree
the recommendation of the officers thank
you
just before i move to council boys it's
just one thing you have a very amazing
point
i don't know if we can
define the size of these caravans
because as far as i'm aware the size of
a caravan is stipulated
in planning law up to a certain size so
it depends how they want to if they want
to cram in a load of big ones we've got
no say on that compared with putting in
a load of little ones jeffy if you allow
me to come back i think you make a valid
point but you know we have to give a
certain amount of weight and credibility
to what the applicant is providing and
and if you look at that you can see the
caravans that they're lowering now are
smaller where they're proposing the
changes compared to elsewhere so you
know it may well be indicative but you
know i think we should be mindful of
that chairman but i have i have made a
proposal but i don't think it's been
seconded yet thank you
did you wish to come back on that
yeah through ceremony yes we
that's right they there is a maximum
size in terms of the carbon sizes um but
then
we approve a layout
on the layout that we approve there are
dimensions on the caravans that's all i
wanted to point out council boyce
uh chairman there's other legislation
that i believe deals uh with caravans
about the spacing uh between them so
that that i'm sure
uh would cover it
um as to council of flukers concerns
about us having the ability
uh to determine this application and
other applications on the council sites
i can assure him that it's perfectly all
right we don't need a dispensation
we have been doing such for many years
i'm not so concerned about the
additional
caravans on the site but
i am
interested in
condition three
which uh
which under three one seven
says that the development hereby
permitted shall be only used as
ancillary to the caravan park proposed
as shown on approved drawings etc etc
and for no other purpose including any
type of residential accommodation at any
time
now i don't know whether the officers
had referred to this
in the report but i seem to remember we
actually
made a conscious decision to put that
condition in
uh and
so what
assurance can we have that that a a
permanent caretaker won't move in or
something like that okay thank you yeah
three determine it's not extensively
discussed within the report because this
element of the proposal the previously
approved proposal is not has not changed
so the multi-purpose building and was
previously
assessed and found acceptable and there
is no change to that
and the condition is imposed because
to give a little bit a little bit of a
history originally there was a proposal
for somebody to be staying on site but
then for flood risk purposes we've
considered that unacceptable at the time
so that's why it's been removed so this
condition is here to secure that no one
will be living on site
permanently okay thank you
council passenger
thank you just just to go back to those
those modelings as you can see that all
of all the caravans uh on the left hand
side are all sort of the same sort of
size and then you go to the right hand
side the the proposed area where the new
caravans are going they've all been
minimized and i was just wondering has
the agent or the the the applicant and
indicated that they will be smaller
caravans or is it just a sort of
illusion
can you see what i'm saying i mean is
that actual are we looking at an actual
thing there are they sort of proposing
different sizes of caravans or
or is that not
determined again there are you can't see
them on the plants but
if you see here there are dimensions on
the um
on its caravan they don't have to submit
elevations or floor plans for caravans
because they they just need to comply
with the caravan act and and the sizes
but there are dimensions on
on the plan so we can control the layout
plan but obviously we wouldn't be able
to control anything that has to do with
appearance of the caravans uh also just
just just to highlight again i did when
i did the presentation the caravan has a
lawful use as a caravan site already so
it can be used as a caravan site yeah
that's correct if i come back so so they
are going to be smaller caravans in that
area where we're having additional
caravans basically
through determined this is what's been
applied this is this is what's been
shown on the layout that we
we're recommending for approval
tonight that's the voice
our second council of fluke's proposal
well it is proposed how do we proposed
and seconded and officer recommendation
to approve
uh those in favor of approval of the
application as can i record your vote
please joe
okay
um
is that second seconded
those in favor of approval please show
abstain
two against extra abstentions thank you
chairman okay thank you very much
okay that is approved we move on to
the gender item
six
which is the cap and feathers in south
street in tillingham
and it's
the proposal is the confirmation of
tpo 3-2-2
and
the reason for referrals committee is
decision on confirmation of a tree
preservation order as per the council
scheme of delegation
and with the recommendation to confirm
the tpo without any modifications
cancer fluke
sorry
i just wanted to raise a point of order
um
in relation i suspect the procedure
rules but i think probably the other
rules apply
um chairman i understand that the
applicant who's appealed this has been
told by the council that he cannot speak
at this meeting which i've well i mean
councillor stamp is wording the question
why against the chamber so i'll echo
that chairman on the basis that i i know
other local authorities when they have
such uh
issues of this to consider they do let
people speak because at the moment we
don't really know
why um
the applicant is is against this and i
think personally he should be given the
opportunity to speak so that said german
i think we're now going to go back to
procedural
21 i think it is um
and and that is gem that we suspend
standing orders and we allow the the
applicant if he so wishes to to address
the committee because nobody's got a
clue otherwise what this is all about
well i don't know the answer
officially on it i mean personally i
don't have any objection i suspect it
would need to be a member's decision but
please thank you thank you chair um i'm
not not quite sure if it's a case that
um
nobody understands what it's about the
application speaks for itself uh there
are two related applications um
um the second one follows on from this
one
the application as many has been
submitted before committee seeks
confirmation of a tree preservation
order
um which has been evaluated and
recommended for such the committee
by officers as has happened many times
before
the second application stems from an
application for works to those
particular trees so i think the
application in front of us here are
quite clear
um i think
if anything i will concede to the fact
that um it may not be fully understood
what the objection is yeah
uh but in terms of the application i
think that it's pretty evident what
what's in front of us thank you chairman
okay um have we uh
canceled mrs chandler and cancer system
thank you leader um yes um chairman i i
can remember something similar coming uh
um i brought it myself uh about a tree
preservation and they the person was
allowed to speak on it so i don't see
what the difference is why the applicant
um it actually i can't remember but it
was um i think it was malden road but i
i know i did it and they were allowed to
speak german so i will second if
councillor fluke is proposing to suspend
standing orders i'll certainly secondary
well i can recall people speaking on
ppos before i'm sure so catch mr channel
thank you chairman
um
just to say i can see where council
fluke is coming from because i don't
recall anything in the constitution
that says regarding certain applications
they can't be public speaking
and at the previous application we just
had we had allowed the agent we had an
application there which one could say
was clearly defined and officer approval
and we might have had views but the
agent on behalf of that becomes allowed
to speak so i'm i'm trying to just work
out what the difference is regarding a
tpo and to me there shouldn't be any
because i don't think our public
participation or speaking defines that
regarding a tpo i don't know if there's
any clause that states that
would you want me to explain it be
helpful
yes please
the council's public speaking protocol
it doesn't allow for speaking in
relation to true preservation it's very
specific
in what areas that public speaking
applies to
and we have taken advice from the
military officer and that was his advice
as well in relation to treatment
chairman i mean yes of course the
monitoring officer will always speak in
favor of the protocol until it gets
changed by members i you know i'm
staggered that that's actually in there
but i think i agree with council stamp
we have allowed this before so i
you know chairman you know the gift of
suspending standing orders and
everything else is is with you um so
you know after i've understood well i've
i've made the i'll make the proposal
chairman that we suspend standing orders
and uh we allow the applicant to speak
uh and i think that will
be
seconded by the
stamp so long as it's within the rules
of two minutes thank you councillor
boyce um
chairman uh i'll i'll need to
refer to miss bird um but i believe the
suspension of standing orders is not as
simple as as
um
a
proposal and a vote
um
so if i could through you chairman
uh ask uh miss bird if if she could
read the relevant
rule
yes certainly miss burke can you do that
fourth please
yeah of course chairman so um rule 21
suspension
standing orders
uh it says all of these procedurals
except numbers 73 13 4 13 5 21 2 may be
suspended by emotion notice or without
notice if at least 16 members of the
council are presented by the consent to
the single majority of those members
suspension can only be for the duration
of the meeting
and then the second paragraph in
relation to that related to mnd
procedurals so chairman can i ask miss
berg while she's got it in front of her
and looking very intensively all right
um does does this fault will you mention
some paragraphs that you can't apply
rule 21 to but my feeling is if you do
supply if you do
if you suspend the procedures rule the
16-member rule doesn't apply
and which then begs another question
that
if you want to suspend standing orders
for any of the programme committees then
you wouldn't be able to do that so i'm
sure that's not what that rule actually
means
two that seems to be relevant to the
council yeah
in respect to the public speaking scheme
it does say that the ultimate management
or public speaking public participation
facilities including tournaments will be
entirely out the discretion of the
council or committee chairman
it would seem to me chairman uh that in
this committee of 11
um
a majority
of uh not a majority but a total number
of at least six members of this
committee would have to vote in favor
of of of that um
as it were pro rattering it down from
um
the 16
uh
and that incl that obviously
also will include those
absent so it's got to be 16 members
present so that would uh be six members
members of this hardly six of us
present tonight so can i ask for all
those who would be in favor of
suspending standing orders for this item
to please show
one two
three four five i'll be the six
in that case we should hopefully be
legal and above board
right anna are you
even says so
here haley please please please present
thank you chairman uh this report thinks
confirmation of a tree principle
preservation order for a group of three
silver birch trees located to the rear
of the cap and feathers in south streets
hillingham
so
the trees are located in this little
circle here
there's a group of three
there's an aerial view of the trees
these are some photographs of the trees
at various places
throughout south street and vicarage
lane so this is from within vickridge
lane looking east at the site to the
rear of the application site
uh this is a little bit closer um to the
rear
this is to the side of the application
site in within vicarage lane
there's a close-up of the three
tree trunks
uh this is a view of the trees from
various places within south street
and trees are indicated
little arrows
some more photos from within south
streets
that was the end of the
presentation
the council received an application to
reduce the height of the trees by 1.5
metres and the removal of a lower branch
overhanging the outside seating area
as it is located within a within the
tillingham conservation area
and the works would require permission
however due to the prominent location
and the size of the trees along with
the lack of agricultural justification
for the works it was considered that the
works would materially impact the
amenity of the area and the future
health of the trees therefore a tempo
assessment was carried out and the trees
scored 20 out of 25 weren't in a tree
preservation order a tree preservation
order was then served on the 29th of
march as an unresolved letter of
objection has been received in relation
to the tpo stating that the resin from
the trees and drops into the garden area
as well as the mess from the pigeons
sitting in the trees
resulting in unusable areas within the
garden also the trees are lifting slabs
causing trip hazards and reducing the
area of garden that is used for seating
the question
of whether or not to confirm the tpo has
been brought before members however it's
the officer's recommendation based on
the immunity value and the long-term
health of the trees and the lack of art
cultural justification for the works
that the tpo should be confirmed thank
you chairman
thank you very much so i believe we do
have somebody wishes to speak on this
center which we've agreed will happen
mr sean cole
if you'd like to step forward
you
the rules account can you have two
minutes to say what you wish to say no
problem apparently there's two minutes
starts to the moment you start speaking
all right thank you very much for
letting me do this
uh
i just sat first
the trees
there's three trees here planted within
1.5 meters long by one meter wide so
and there are some 18 inches around eat
all of them
so that's they're very bunched up in one
group
uh now i've had confirmation in 1976
these trees were about 15 to 20 feet
tall
so if you take that roughly 1970 though
they were
uh planted that makes them 52 years old
which a useful life of a silver birch
searched everywhere it's 40 to 60 years
it's a lifespan for a silver bird so
they're coming to the end of their life
anyway
uh as it spits before these are lifting
patio slabs causing triples in my garden
at least 25 of the gardens lost because
of this
sat in the spring covers cars in the car
park covers all the sleeting area
et cetera and tables and the pigeons and
i've used various pigeon scarers which
don't work at all they do for a short
time but they stop working there's mess
everywhere all over the garnet fence all
over the beer
etcetera now i'm asking to be removed
and at the end of the day i don't
replace him if i don't go but i'm not
asking for removed it just impacts on
the business
generally for me
now my understanding the difference
between a tpo and these trees are
located in our conservation land
so the only difference between a tpo and
trees on conservation land is if they
fall down or die
i have to replace them under a tpo but
under conservation i don't
i don't see the reason why i don't want
to replace them
uh and both need permission to prune it
so i can't do anything to these trees
without
getting the council's permission
now the other thing is i believe there's
a three to four hundred year old oak in
the park opposite
that's been pruned and hacked to pieces
and there's no tpo on this tree
and
i just feel victimized because of this
to be honest i think the council were
not handling this very well at all
thank you okay thank you very much
mr johnson
sorry just the point there just that we
need to focus on the
trees which are the subject of this
application anything outside of that in
terms of the application is a personal
opinion
thank you chairman
right any members wish to comment on
this
cancer fluker
well no it's not it's counseling julius
ward actually um
yeah i mean look german it's as far as
trees and tillingham have been
you know concerned it's been quite a
distressing week and i i hear what mr
johnson says you know we're looking at
this from the point of view of a
tbo
um
so
you know i can see where where the
council is coming from this but i think
we we really have to be mindful of the
fact that these trees
are getting towards the end of their
life um i know that i know from the
neighbors
um that a lot of the diocese of twigs
and leaves and everything else come off
the trees when the wind's in south
westerly and sort of heads towards those
those cottages left and i know they're
concerned about the height of these
trees but i think you know we do need to
focus on whether or not it's in the best
interest of
the conservation area whether to have
the tpo or not my view is chairman is
that if the trees were to fail over the
next couple of years and the applicant
is then obliged to plant three new trees
that's not going to resolve any of these
problems whether it's now or
you know for our successes in title
because we're still going to have
problems with with them affecting the
business area at the back they're still
going to be
um you know
bits are going to come flying off onto
the houses nearby so
i
i you know i don't really see the point
of doing this and and i i don't
understand chairman and and i know look
we've got to look at precedent you know
we always get told to look at president
and you've got this situation where
you've got a 350 year old oak tree in
the conservation area in the park which
look i'm not on a boriculturist but i
cannot believe what that looks like now
i must agree with you
there wasn't a tbo put on it and it's in
the conservation area so why one and why
not the other
um you know chairman i i will not
support putting the tpo on this because
i think it will be
totally counterproductive and there is
absolutely no gain to the conservation
area or this council to do it because
the only difference will be is if the
tree dies it's got to be replanted and
then the
the applicant will come back and say
well actually no you know there's just
so much time seems to be invested in
this i mean since this application came
in i think in february i think the
report says four months ago that tree's
probably grown a meter so we got to the
stage where you know it's taken so long
the tree's larger he's going to be
making another application next year um
i i can't support it chairman i really
cannot support it thank you
thank you mr johnson
thank you chairman um just
as obviously
some comparison in approaches have been
drawn with this tree uh elsewhere in the
area in tillingham
um
just for clarification that tree or the
works of that tree is part of a
maintenance program
of which this round of work so those
trees are not the first
works of those trees back in 2014 the
trees were
similarly
pruned in that particular way
and then it's grown to what it is so
that that that is that is the reported
um record of the works that have been
carried out to those trees
so i just wanted to just make that that
particular point and i think you know i
mean
we also need to be
aware of the consistency of the
decisions we're making because arguments
about you know leaves falling and
you know tree sap and
and probably birds in the trees have
been made by many an applicant on
applications for trees in in a similar
situation and
these have been discounted for the
greater good of the trees which we
consider to have high immunity value
through an established
regulatory assessment system so it's not
something that's just blocked out of the
air it's something which is quite
definite and it's a standard which we
use in terms of
all these applications that come to us
in that way and to which in many cases
or at least all the cases i know we do
give great weight so then to sort of
discard it for
and again i would add in the officer's
report it has been pointed out that
arguments have not been justified there
would need to be a particular
arboricultural justification
um but for the works there was no
reasonable arboricultural justification
there's been no evaluation
of the impact of the tree roots in terms
of the area now i'm not saying that
there isn't any but it just hasn't been
demonstrated
um also within the report as in all
these reports it does says that it does
not mean that words can't be carried out
to this tree it does not mean that if
there's justification that comes later
on if the tree is protected you know an
alternative way of managing the tree
can't be considered but to
take that away at this stage for a tree
which figures quite highly i mean i've
been here where we've had trees which
have
you know they've they've they've had 15
on the 10 the tempo scheme out of 25 and
we consider that to be quite highly
valued this is not this is 20 on the
scheme so i'd be quite concerned about
how we take a decision on that basis
thank you chairman i mean i would
i don't i don't
understand myself the need to put a tpo
on this when basically any works cov
to be carried out on that tree are
covered by
the conservation
area anyway so as has been pointed out
elsewhere i mean the only thing is it
would it would mean that if
we had a nice big gale this winter that
blew them over
the applicant would have to or the owner
would have to replace with three new
trees which i wouldn't have to do if we
just left it without a tpo on it and to
be quite honest having seen the mess and
i can't describe it as anything less
that has been made within eyesight of
these trees of oak on the other side of
the playing field i went and looked at
it this morning and it is an absolute
disgrace
i cannot believe what's happened to it
as a personal view as a gardener and
somebody who planted
and let grow hundreds of trees i just
think it looks appalling i know council
fluke has sent round a few photographs
of it to various people but
everybody this weekend coming will see
it from the flashover i mean it's just
dreadful and that we are now saying that
we can tell other people how they can
look after their trees or not i'm i'm
just i'm just disgusted by it i really
am it may not be relevant to this
application as such
but
if you go and have a look please
how's the fluke
so let me come back an unconscious fact
other people want to speak but look i
mean
paragraph 5.3 seems to be sort of a
contrary comment to what we've just
heard because it says the tempo which is
designed as a guide a guide to decision
making only a guide to decision making
making member in 5.3 but
mr johnson talks about consistency well
i mean members of this committee will
remember
um uh mrs babzos who i know is known to
you all from from a place called if i've
got the
base camp based base camp riverside road
where this council tried to put a tpo on
a tree in the conservation area a
leyland iconifer yeah which was like
these very near the end of their life
and from the point of view of
consistency
this committee refused it and i believe
quite rightly and then
we've got consistency chairman whereby
you know mr johnson talks about
consistency and the importance of
agreeing these and and i would say
normally i would support this and not
least of all you know i've planted
hundreds of trees over the years but
you do have to look at the oak they've
they've applied to do some work on it
uh i don't believe it's been executed
according to the planning permission but
the officers do so i have to accept that
but at no stage
did the council say to the owner of the
oak tree we're going to put a tpo on it
and that is that oak tree in my mind is
so important
that and why no tpo has been put on it
since this works been carried out i i'm
sorry i don't get it i don't think this
is consistent and you know i think we're
we're treating this person differently i
think to other people so i stand by what
i said to him and i don't think this
committee should agree the granting of a
tpo thank you
uh councilman stamp
thank you chairman um i'm actually going
to be on the rare occasion yet again
agreeing with councillor fluker i see
that i don't get used to it because i'm
sure it won't continue
that's what planning meetings are
but um i see it as a sledgehammer's
cracker nut
is a good old northern saying i think
and i think we're being heavy-handed i
certainly agree with that tree i was
absolutely
distraught when i saw the picture of the
after of that tree i couldn't believe it
we've all got trees that my next-door
neighbour's got trees bigger than that
do you want to come and put tpos on that
because seriously they they cause the
roots are coming up in our gardens so i
think we do need some consistency here
um
i i'm also going to agree i'm not going
to support the council the
recommendation chairman thank you for
those members who don't know the other
side of the playing field at tillingham
three weeks ago was a magnificent oak
tree and today it's a skeleton with
literally 99 percent of its leaves
removed and branches removed it's awful
absolutely dreadful
yeah either the pictures don't do don't
do the don't do the fact justice council
council messenger
yeah mr chairman i'd just like to say i
mean we've all seen the uh the um the
pictures that uh council of fluker sent
and i must say they are absolutely
shocking
and to think i mean tree there's trees
and trees and if you look at silver
birches you know they do become a
nuisance they grow very tall they get
very leggy and they do need to be looked
after otherwise they just become like a
conifer they just become an eyesore
if you're looking at an oak which i know
we're not supposed to be talking about
now that's something that needs
protected and i just cannot believe that
that was allowed to happen and whoever
conducted that work
you know they are butchers and it's
shocking
so
you know i absolutely agree with
everything that's been said and and just
to just to go over it again you know
this is a tree that's in a conservation
area these trees so they are already
protected so
as councillor stamp said we are sort of
over we're over egging this a bit i
think
that's mrs chenna
thank you chairman
um bearing in mind the proximity of
trees
to the
rear garden the pub and the seating area
actually the report does make reference
to the health of the trees but are there
ramifications of the trees having a tpo
stuck on with all due respect pigeons
and pigeon droppings falling onto an
eating area
i mean i'm just wondering if there's any
associated views there
the input may put an onus on the council
should we agree to a tp i know that some
might sound off the wall because i don't
know enough about these but we're
talking about health of trees what about
health of patrons to the public to the
pub and sitting in the garden and
there's a tree in close proximity
whereby they're eating or i know the the
owner might have a responsibility to
clear a table or what have you but it's
easier said than done sometimes so i'm
wondering if there's any health and
safety issues by association
well many many years ago i went to
mary's wood agricultural college which
in its day was
one of the best if not the best library
cultural colleges in the country and
all the all members of all courses did a
crash course in the other courses so one
day we did trees and i remember a
lecturer down there one of the tree
lecture was saying that no tree should
ever be planted or allowed to grow
within falling distance of a dwelling
or
um or place of habitation because a big
tree will go straight through a building
from top to bottom so just embarrassing
but anyways anybody else got anything to
say
if i may i mean again we're not we're
not advocating that these trees are
going to be chopped down all we're
saying is
you know we just want them you know they
could be looked after and that's correct
i think that's that's a proper
way to behave with trees they they need
pruning simple as that
mr johnson
the very last point there just in terms
of what council channel was saying
um i think it's more the case of um
where are the tables placed rather than
where the tree already exists
just wanted to just sort of make that
point because if we
if we if we work on the basis that um
a beer garden is so positioned around
the tree but then the tree becomes a
nuisance
does it not raise the question of where
are the are the tables meant to be there
in the first place or could there not be
somewhere else on the side i just wanted
to make that point it is a pub garden
the tables may have come before the tree
it's a bit chicken to dig that one isn't
it i think german i'll have to invite mr
johnson to have a look at the garden
it's not very big
but anyway members we are being asked to
confirm the tree preservation order
without any modifications to it do
members wish to agree to confirm it or
do you not wish to agree to confirm it
i'd propose chairman that we don't
confirm it uh on the grounds that we
think that um i think one that the trees
are afforded enough protection by virtue
of the fact they're in the conservation
area and i think with all seriousness
german they are getting towards the end
of life end and i think it would burden
the owner of the prophecy if they had to
replace them in the future because it's
not going to alleviate the problems so
chairman that's that is my proposal
thank you okay is that second dude
that's secondly by council mrs channel
is it shannon this is damn i'm terribly
sorry i'm major major brain fade tonight
we need the ball
now back to reality i'm sorry about that
but um
the proposal
julie seconded
is that we do not confirm that
pre-preservation order members when
those in favor of that would they please
show
one two three four five and any against
none so in that case that we do not
confirm the tpo
so
i've got terrible difficulty at the
moment placing where sounds come from so
i'm sorry about that i had to start at
the end and look round
i don't think it's relevant to this item
no but i really don't know the answer to
that
do we do we have an answer or
thank you thank you chairman uh that can
be considered obviously on its merits
and subject to all other factors thank
you chairman okay
happy birthday
we move on
to agenda item seven which again is the
same trees
and it's captain feathers in
and it's the proposal is
to
crown reduce i think it's just one of
these threes by for one and a half
meters
there's three trays in the group
it just mentions g1 here yeah that's the
group of the three oh i see right there
but we should but we should
add that this tpo is only dependent on
the confirmation of the tpo otherwise
this application falls away because we
can't approve or refuse works on a tree
that doesn't have a tree preservation
order again this would have to come back
as a separate application
for work to be carried out it would have
to come back as an application as works
to trees within a conservation area
because they're obviously located in the
crossfire movement the trees will not be
touched
yep there's no there could be no
permission granted for those trees this
evening um
happy with that
really
chairman because you know by the time we
get this back to south east planning
committee it's going to be another eight
weeks i suspect i don't think it would
come necessarily to south east and
by then that the trees will have
grown another meter chairman so perhaps
we can have some clarity i can see
there's a deep conversation about when
what would happen to this i mean german
i mean while they're while they're
discussing it um
tillingham village council doesn't have
any uh views on this at all in fact
from what i heard they were quite keen
on having them reduced at night because
of everything that's going on but
chairman i'll give way to the officers
who are about to tell me this can be
decided tomorrow
through you chairman um tca applications
can't be called into committee
and they're determined by under
delegated authority due to the
legislation so you can't call in the
only it can only be tpo
wtpo applications or confirmation of
tpos that can come to a planning area
committee
i mean that being the case because
you know i must admit when i looked at
the reason why i called this into
committee was because of the the
conditions so i i hope you'll just you
know afford me for a moment for the
benefit of the officers
for the benefit of the officers that's
it i've got your attention now so what
now that's fine it's one of the one of
the conditions was the fact of using a
mobile platform to do this which in that
location would be absolutely horrendous
i appreciate that the tree if somebody
climbs it or whatever
um
the yes it can do some internal damage
and we know they are brittle but i think
you should be mindful as to the location
and perhaps rather than having a mobile
platform which generates all sorts of
other problems whether or not we could
clarify a condition that says that they
can be pruned a meter and a half which i
think you agree in principle anyway in
this report but in such a way as the
tree isn't damaged and that then allows
that then allows for example a
scaffolding to be built on the other
side and it then doesn't mean that the
applicant has got a huge cost because i
can see the applicants coming back next
year and saying well i'm going to have
to do this again but perhaps the council
can help with the cost because it's
grown so much during this period of time
but i would be grateful chairman for the
benefit of the applicant who's here if
the officers could indicate bearing in
mind they've done everything for this
report whether or not they can indicate
how quickly they can make a decision and
issue a decision notice on these works
thank you
thank you
the um we can't add conditions onto tc
applications there isn't a facility for
that it's done under a legislation so we
can add it onto a wtpo application
because it's a protected tree but we
can't put that onto a tci application um
the tca application that was received
which resulted in the tpo being served
the decision of the application was the
tpo being served so we would require a
new uh works to a tree in a conservation
area application to be submitted and it
would have to go through the six-week
consultation period before a decision
could be issued in line with the
legislation uh we can't
change the decision on the previous
application because the decision was
made to serve the tpo
john i'm surrounded by disappointed
faces but i think one thing sure we've
all learnt a lot tonight we should be
grateful for the officers for putting us
all right thank you
okay my members anybody else wanted to
discuss that in any shape form or no
in that case we'll move on to a gender
item eight which is any other items of
business which the chairman decides our
urgent i have none
counsellor mrs stamp
chairman just to let everybody know that
the it team have finished at burnhamtown
council offices for south east planning
to go back there hooray
they brought the keys back to my house
at six o'clock tonight and they're all
done and ready to go when we meet next
it'll be you should be at spurnum
super job thank you very much for that
in which case i close this meeting at 8
30. precisely thank you very much